spring is in the air in europe but so
too
is something less welcome something that
is also having its rebirth
much of the continent is eyeing a
looming third wave of coronavirus
19 countries are now reporting
increasing
case numbers 15 member states are
reporting
increased hospital and icu admissions
while eight
member states are now reporting
increased number of of deaths
with more covid19 infections comes agony
about
lockdowns belgium is shuttering schools
non-essential shops and hairdressers
until late april germany can't decide
what to do
angela merkel has apologized and
cancelled a hastily planned
five-day easter lockdown after a
political backlash
a mistake needs to be called a mistake
and above all it must be corrected
and if possible this needs to happen as
soon as possible
at the same time i am aware that this
whole business has created even more
uncertainty
and i deeply regret this and i ask for
forgiveness
europe's repeating misery comes as it
tries to sort out its beleaguered
vaccination program
in the eu only 10 percent of the adult
population has received a jab so far
by contrast the uk has already injected
more than half
the european commission is planning
tighter rules on vaccine exports to
protect already reduced
eu supply it says it's not targeting any
particular country
but it wants the situation to be more
reciprocal
since the introduction of the export
authorization
system some 10 million doses had been
exported from uk from eu
to uk and zero doses have been exported
from uk
to eu according to the french government
29 million astrazeneca vaccine doses
were discovered at the weekend
in a police inspection of a plant in
italy the drug maker insists
most were for eu consumption not export
france says a shipment block should be
considered if that's not true
it adds confusion to an already fraught
atmosphere
rory challenge al jazeera